[Music]
do any of you guys
snore i know girls count here no do i
snore
uh yes when you get fat or you snore
like right now you're snoring
because you're fatter but he's doing it
on purpose he's getting
are you bulking right now no it's just
you know like trying to help right now
at the gym you have to
wear a face mask so it's just kind of
hard to do cardio
so i'm like i'm just not going to do
cardio
i've been getting chunkier well that's
not what makes you fat not the fact that
you're not doing cardio it's just
that you're eating like crazy and i'm
eating like that's what's really causing
it
yeah so you're not doing it for for
bulking reasons
well you know when you wear a face mask
it's easier to wear to eat a burger and
pizza
it's easier because you've been
restricted all day so you can't wait to
[ __ ]
sometimes i snore so loud i wake myself
up oh [ __ ] you have sleep apnea maybe
nah dude i just died nah bruh
yeah you just shook that right off no no
i think [ __ ] dude i think i do
i think i choked myself from snoring oh
[ __ ] you snore now
i've been snoring oh what about do you
use the easy breathings yeah
i don't know you should do the bart
technique where he has the nose opener
and then the mouth cover i do that too
oh [ __ ] can you still snore
well i don't always do it oh okay yeah
do you know because somebody else is in
the bed with you
okay yeah oh yeah or do you wake
yourself up but also i was on
i was doing van life with my buds and
then they're like yeah
you better we better go to sleep before
joe does that sucks you're that guy
well they all snore is what i heard you
don't want to be the last person to
sleep did you hear them
no because i was the first one sleeping
every year nikki's family they all get
together for christmas and they all like
sleep in the same
room in the same house and i
single-handedly ruined that tradition
oh [ __ ] they no longer do that everyone
gets hotels yeah thank god by the way
we're all sleeping on the floor and [ __ ]
i'm like i'm too old for this [ __ ]
right that's cute though like a slumber
party
it's cute until you wake up in the
morning you just fell asleep on the
floor and you're like i wish i had
family like that
yeah but that floor hurts yeah we all
get hotels now everything's better
yeah more comfortable the only time i
like sleeping on the floor is when i'm
coming down from ecstasy
and what does the floor do for you i
don't feel it
that's true that's really good or it
feels really nice it feels like a
tempurpedic
for some reason well the reason why i
ask is because
apparently there are clinical trials in
the u.s right now
for a pill that could help you stop
snoring
oh i don't know about these pills what's
the side effect
no free lunches in nature i know right
i'm glad you asked it caused [ __ ]
i'll wait for the vaccines that's right
will cause vomiting or before i tell you
the side effects because they're
pretty anal eruptions it feels like the
side effects is always
worse than what it's trying to cure yeah
it's like upset stomach
well guess what you're gonna get cancer
but at least your stomach pains will go
away
replaced with [ __ ] arthritis or some
[ __ ] or anal vomiting yeah like what
it's always something i've never heard
of i just pictured my [ __ ]
like involving
mine may cause heartburn and diarrhea
but your headaches will go away
yeah well uh well before i tell you the
side effects though they are saying
that the this pill are these two
non-sleep related drugs when they're
combined
they reduce snoring frequency uh
by 74 why so they go from an average of
28.5 breathing interruptions per hour to
just
7.5 wow and these
drugs uh one of them where'd they go
or we could just stop being fat asses
it's not boner pills it's not violent
because when i took viagra it stuffed up
my nose
really yeah i took a blue chew i took
two blue chews
how to do it they're called blue chews
yeah well then you know when they became
generic
after viagra loss you know the the
patent or whatever the copyright
because it increases blood flow so it
increases blood flow and then ice
you know it gets gets up you have a rock
hard guy
but yeah but this is what you sound like
like make love to me
so it's not one of those drugs is not
violence
no see
i thought it would be the floor i had
low tea
testosterone that's what you thought i
do kind of almost
very i'm on the lower side of it okay i
got tested
okay and so and i wasn't my libido was
just
dog [ __ ] you know maybe you were sad
well that's a big part of it yeah
and so i couldn't get horny and i
thought if i took
everything they put advertised viagra
like oh the guy's swinging a golf club
and he's like got a big old smile he's
waiting for his wife to come home but
that's not the thing that would make me
horny
it doesn't do that it just gives you uh
uh blood down there when you get a boner
it keeps it
it doesn't give you doesn't help you get
a boner
any quicker at least in my experience
just gave me a stuffy nose and like
i've bought it for too long too long how
long was it
minutes well you had to give yourself
the butter you have to give yourself the
bonus that's not what i
understood that's not what i thought was
being promised to me
exactly yeah i'm scared of that kind of
[ __ ] but you should try one i have a
bunch
i think they're expired but who knows
yeah i'll give you i'll try because i
heard that
if you don't then you do it it [ __ ] up
your penis like it over stretched it out
or something
it doesn't feel like it should be in
your body that's stuff when you take it
oh really
it just go away after you ejaculate kind
of made you sweaty excuse me did it go
away after you ejaculate it's a very
personal question
it's very scientific if you ask me if
it's within because i took two it kind
of stayed
which makes it very uncomfortable
because i wanted it to work
oh wait what state the stuff your nose
the boner oh okay so the stuffy nose
went away but the boner stayed
the boner and you're just kind of like
standing there no one hangs around for
how long did you have a boner for i
thought it was so personal steve
honestly it was probably close to
like 30 minutes which for me is like a
lifetime
lifetime because i thought four hours
was a long time like that's usually when
they're like if it's four hours you have
to go
it's called priapism and you gotta go to
the doctor yeah i heard
like some guys were just like yeah it's
[ __ ] hours maybe it was just 20
minutes
you can you have to get your penis
amputated if they can't
uh if it doesn't go away and the blood
doesn't they can't drain it they inject
you with something if the drain doesn't
work
the last step we did a story about a guy
that had
that experience i don't remember maybe
that's where i learned it
i'm also a fan oh yeah can you imagine
having a boner and then you watch once a
time
put on time in hollywood and it's still
there yeah the whole time dude that and
that's a long
feeling movie too it's not even just a
long movie it also feels long yeah
yeah chad does feel free i
when he picks up the hot girl and she
bends over at the car
i like the foot scenes those are fun i
like the electrocution
scene when the girl gets electrocuted i
thought
you know this is probably for the next
step but i thought leonardo dicaprio's
better than he's been in most movies oh
he's fantastic yeah
so funny he just didn't give him
anything to do i thought
yeah it was a very boring role i agree
with most things that you say
not this one i get it hey look i get it
i loved when you called out indians
before and you're like hey you're taking
all our jobs i love that
i'm just tired of them coming to this
country i loved it and taken all our
jobs
well he didn't he was in berlin okay a
different video you have to find it
he'll eventually get here anyway back to
this thing
so the two drugs one of them is the adhd
drug
and the other one is used to treat
urinary inconstant
inconstant incontinence what that means
you can't get it
um yeah i've actually had a case sorry
i've had a case of not being able to pee
once
wow how long did that take this is
another gross story
you had the feeling but you had the
feeling and i was in big berry it was i
was
a freezing b the night before i had
masturbated with
um like a herbal essence conditioner in
the shower and i think some got in my
urethra
and uh the next day couldn't could
barely pee
why'd you use conditioner the herbal
conditioner stays
it keeps the liver way better for lube
was it the grapefruit one
um yeah the herbal essence it was the
one that
all the girls were listening to the
herbal essence commercial because those
who are crazy
they're like yes yes yeah yes
yeah exactly did it go in your pee hole
and it got stuck
well it must have i must have got some
sort of infection because
i had the feeling to go pee so bad and
there we were it was a snow storm took
13 hours to come down off this mountain
i couldn't pee i was almost crying and
the
lens popped out of my glasses that's
probably the saddest moment
[ __ ] all the stuff damn series of
unfortunate events
yeah i'm so happy you're here today i i
almost didn't make it yeah
why did the lens pop we slid off the
mountain into the off the road into the
mountain i
i got into another friend's car that got
a flat tire i mean i'm telling you it
was a goddamn nightmare
you're never going skiing again bring
bad luck i'm a yeah
a bad juju for sure you're never coming
back dude
dark energy oh great we have to say to
this place
do you like snowboarding still no no
that never happened
broke my thumb january trying to snow
was that your first time snowboarding it
was like my seventh
which might as well be my first i i
don't know what i'm doing out there
yeah well do you guys want to hear the
side effects yeah yeah
sorry it says
uh so there's both physical and mental
side effects
holy [ __ ] uh so it's abdominal
abdominal discomfort and constipation oh
no
and mood swings and suicidal thoughts
perfect
that's it how how is it that when you
hear all these side effects
right a lot of the times you do hear
suicidal thoughts
and i'm like how does that come from a
pill how do you get suicidal thoughts
from a pill
no isn't that crazy like chemical
imbalance or something yeah it's like a
chemical like i want to kill myself
after taking this pill so i don't
[ __ ] snore anymore pills can really
shift your [ __ ] around for sure yeah but
it smells like a tongue twister shift
your [ __ ] you can't
but i gotta say i did uh i did accutane
uh in my youth yeah i remember suicidal
thoughts is part of that one too that's
what they said but i already had those
because your face is all [ __ ] up from
acne and you don't even want to go
outside
right and every month you go in for a
blood test and they go how are you
feeling bud
you have like you okay yeah yeah they do
your blood they go hey you all right and
you go yeah
is it getting better they're like no it
gets worse before it gets better exactly
your face explodes first that was the
second saddest moment in my life what's
accutane is it
like it shrinks your oil gland muscle or
whatever it is that produces the oil and
it makes you drop it
dries you up yep just like any woman
watching this
episode right now exactly i'm pretty dry
just dried up a whole bunch of dabs
like look at like his these are that's
what that's i was so constipated one
time i [ __ ] a perfect ball
you're like a rabbit there's like a
bocce ball wow
you need to drink water and eat fiber no
i was young
when i was young but i raised it as my
[Music]
own
you